Hey, welcome back to 40 Days of Holiness.
Today, we're talking about holiness and the will.
Now, I want to talk to you real quickly about something about
the human spirit. So we are divided into mind, we think.
Will, we choose. And emotions, we feel.
So yesterday, we talked about holiness and the mind, and
how God reprograms the mind to think appropriately,
and think in cooperation with the growing
holiness of your heart and life. All right?
So we talked about that one yesterday.
Today, we're talking about holiness and the will.
Now, in the scripture,
there's these terminologies. These terms may not be always
defined super-duper clearly.
But in terms of the scripture, the will is the
chooser, the selector of the path
in yourself, in your life, in your way of being.
And so the will is an important part of
the equation. I would say maybe even the
key part of the equation because we don't always
understand with the mind what the will is doing.
Sometimes people are just wrong about why they choose to do what they do.
They say, "Oh, I do it because of this," but they actually do it because of
something else. So the will is often, is
in some ways the core of the corruption, that which is
corrupted and twisted by the sin nature.
Our will to do right is literally taken away from
us in our lost state, so that
we literally can't do right because our
motivations, our will is corrupted.
So even when we do an action that is right, we're like the
Pharisees, and the action that is right is corrupted by the idol of
self.
So once we are saved and
our will is cleansed and the sin
nature is cleansed from our life and our heart,
what then is next? Well, the answer is that our wills
are baby wills.
They are small. We are not
well full-grown in terms of self-control, and
our will is really weak sometimes.
So what do you do when you find that your will is weak, when
you're trying to be a holy person? Well, the answer is that you
must grow in willpower. You must grow in willpower.
There's really a lot of interesting research being done in
today's world about willpower. Willpower is
not something that you either have or don't have.
Some people think, "Well, I just was born without any willpower.
Those people, they have strong willpower, but I don't."
Well, there's maybe some natural inclination one direction or
another, but the truth is that you have a
resource of willpower. It's not something you have or you don't have.
It's like a battery. And it may be a small little double A battery at
the beginning, but you can grow that and increase that, and you can grow
its capacity, its ability to hold a charge of
willpower if you want, and if you like to use that analogy.
There are some very, very fascinating things that, and I would point you
to my resource called the Habits Masterclass.
If you're interested in that, get in touch with me and I'll tell you how to get a
hold of it.
But the Habits Masterclass deals with habits and
willpower and all that, and how to grow your
power in that area of your life. Here's what I would tell you.
First of all, I would tell you your
willpower can grow in capacity. The second thing I would tell you is that
your willpower is at its best when you are
undistracted. If you have a
lot of noise and a lot of chaos in your life,
you need to create space and solitude
because it will grow your willpower. I'm telling you, it will.
Now, if you have a lot of things like kids and stuff like that, I do, then you're
going to need to intentionally create space
and do things that protect and care for your willpower
and grow its capacity in your life.
They did a study some years ago where they brought in people,
and they brought in college students, and they had a snack cart.
And 50% of them, they said, "Wait right
here and we're going to come back, but while we're waiting, would you get a snack?
Also, we want you to remember this number.
Just remember this phone number for us, and we'll be back in two minutes." They
left, they selected a snack, and they came back.
And the other group, they told them, "Wait two minutes, get a snack
from the cart. Choose a snack, and we'll be back in two minutes." And they came
back, but no phone number.
The group that had to remember the phone number was far more
likely to select an unhealthy snack.
Do you know why? Because their mind was
distracted and it lessened their willpower.
So I would just encourage you to live a life that is less
distracted. If there are things in your life that are always chaotic, and the radio
and the TV's always going in the background, and you have no space to think, and no
space to recharge, and no space to be quiet before the Lord,
you need to create that.
You need to shut off the radio in the car
and just be quiet and let the Lord speak.
You know why? It'll increase your willpower. It will.
Additionally, I would tell you to not tax your willpower for
things that you can routinize, things that are good
for you, that are habits of holiness.
You should focus on developing routines and habits
because it will save your willpower.
It will save your willpower for when you need it intentionally. All right?
So you need to develop willpower, develop habits and routines
so that you could rescue your willpower.
And so if you'll do that, and you'll choose to use your will
wisely. You have a mind, you have a will, and you have
emotions. Tomorrow we'll talk about emotions.
Actually, for the next couple of days, we'll talk about emotions.
But today, I just want to give you a little bit of a picture of how God can
use the will and the willpower, and grow your willpower so
your will becomes your friend in the
producing of the growth of holiness in your life.
God bless you. Talk to you tomorrow.